it's gonna be a close-out game biambo
trying to slam it a close-out game
coming up with a foul called
and now words between biambo and and
chris
so phoenix has won when they played at
home dallas was one and they've played
at home
yeah this is setting up to be
chris is gone a masterful game in game
six uh-oh
chris
[Applause]
has gone running into the tunnel
well i believe their locker room is back
that
way it looks like there's a lot of
concern
oh now here's the question was biambo
that's why security is running down
there if we can show that
security has run into the tunnel because
both players
who are heading down the same tunnel yes
the locker room for the suns is behind
their bench and that's the concern
now chris is back on the floor here
and now chris
is going out another way leaving the
floor
in back of the bench
here's the thing they didn't want
something to escalate in the back so he
went to go look for i think in years
past we saw that with like a doug
christie and a rick fox remember that
when they ran into the back see there's
biambo you can see biambo in the
distance
and some very alert
that's smart by the security personnel
for both teams yes it is
because i believe biambo was heading to
his locker room
betty took